[Music]
it is four months since the russian
invasion of ukraine
marked with what could be an important
win for russia
governor says ukrainian troops will have
to pull back from saviro donetsk a city
bombed to bits and almost surrounded
moscow claims it has encircled about 2
000 ukrainian fighters nearby including
80 foreigners
ukraine says russia's next target is the
neighboring city of lichansk that would
give russia full control over luhansk
one of two regions that make up the
donbass
the other is donetsk
i just want to be taken out of here now
my mental health is already crippled
says this woman she blames ukrainian
forces for bombing her home in the
russian controlled main city
ukraine hopes to counter russia's
advance with more western supplied
weapons kiev now says it has received
its first delivery of u.s highmars
long-range missiles
a day after the eu approved ukraine's
candidacy russia's foreign minister says
that poses no threat to russia but at
the same time he compared the eu and
nato's expansion plans to hitler's
preparations for the second world war a
million miles from war one of the
world's largest music festivals
greetings lastenburg president vladimir
zelinsky opened the event glastonbury is
the greatest concentration of freedom
these days continuing his worldwide pr
campaign calling on everyone not to
forget ukraine redmond shannon global
news london